first up he is the former Democratic
governor of Virginia and author of the
New York Times best-selling book Beyond
Charlottesville's
taking a stand against white nationalism
Terry McAuliffe so you're very apropos
for this week you're talking about
trellis rose almost exactly two years
ago is that right all new years ago
Monday right okay so what what happened
in Charlottesville was they were out
loud and proud they came out of the
shadows you better come from under the
rock so mass right no masks right
these were office Park Nazis yeah okay
some of them got in trouble for that yep
now it seems they've gone back
underground which is better to have them
out in the open or in the shadows out
the open get them exposed Friday night
he remember they came on the grounds of
the University of Virginia hundreds with
their torches marching onto the campus
screaming Jews you will not replace us
blood and soil will out of what you
heard in 1933 1934 Nazi Germany and then
Saturday a thousand neo-nazis white
supremists their swastikas Adolf Hitler
ideology and just the most vile things
I've ever heard in my life so if if
Trump is a white nationalist as a lot of
people are saying and he has a 42
percent approval rating what does that
say to you it's not a good place for our
country to be in I mean I wrote this
book I called him out that
I called him out that day he came out as
a full-fledged racist and white
Nationals during Charlottesville I
talked to him that day I told the
president what was happening I begged
him to come out this was his opportunity
to heal the nation he didn't he came out
and said they were good people on both
sides bill they were not good people on
the neo-nazi in white supremacist I'd
think we could all agree on that
except for Trump he refused to do it
yeah okay so do you think this next
election is going to be on the up and up
oh I'm very concerned Russia is gonna be
as active as they've ever been
yeah it bills introduced in Congress
Mitch McConnell won't bring them up I'm
very concerned I mean I could tell you
in Virginia when I was governor I had to
replace all the machines because I
remember when I first voted when I went
to Richmond move down as governor I
remember I kept vote in the Senate race
kept voting for the Democrat Republican
name kept coming up three times that
happened
what do you mean kept coming up so I you
know we had the touch screens I was
voting for Mark Warner our senator and
Ed glossaries name was light up happened
to me three times finally the fourth
time marked name and I quickly hit vote
and I got out of there you know all the
cameras are look at me like this guy
doesn't know how to vote I mean what's
going on so then I had an investigation
done and listen to this I brought in
some technology experts they were able
to hack into our machines from off-site
in about five or six minutes and within
four minutes they were able to change a
vote ID decertified all the machines now
in Virginia we have paper ballots
yeah so how do you handicap this race so
far but obviously the Democratic Party
which you've been a part of and
influential in for a very long time
yeah they're having a fight as parties
do between the left and the center what
is going to carry the day in this so I'm
confident we're gonna be Trump I mean I
remember we lost three don't say that
no but I'm confident yeah we were
confident last time it's not a good
thing it's confident but listen three
states we lost minds not confident we're
gonna beat Trump so you better [ __ ]
well we not confident 92 million people
did not vote okay you got to get him out
we got to fire them up we got to win
those how then okay so what do you think
centrists or the are you for Medicare
for all are you for expanding Obama and
I hate these labels is governor you know
I enhance a policy got things done
created the wreckage a bus that's policy
Medicare for all or Obamacare Obamacare
okay well that's just taking the next
level right don't scare people with
socially the idea you're attacking Joe
Biden for President Obama's policies who
is one of our most popular president
doesn't make a lot of sense to me that
is a dumb strategy so are you for Biden
is that who your person listen I love
them all I've known the vice president
the longest I think he's got a great
message I think he is the best chance of
beating Trump but I mean this week he
said a couple of things I mean you know
he doesn't mean it
yeah you know he said something about
poor kids are just as smart as white
kids and then he said we believe in in
facts not true truth yeah
no truck over facts there's going to be
some senior moments yes with Joe Biden
right don't don't we just have to get
used to that that there is no I do you
think it now and people are gonna try to
link that to like Kenny actually do the
job I don't think there is a realistic
link there I don't think he's about to
push the button or he thinks he's moving
the remote and he blows up Russia
i I don't in a guy who has lied
just just certified ten thousand times
since he's been in office you're gonna
talk to me about Joe Biden you got Trump
out there every single day Brian tell
the truth I mean come on but I'm just
saying I think that day the week we need
to just but I'm just saying we we need
to get used to the fact that if he's the
nominee there's going to be some senior
moments and we can't lose our [ __ ] every
time there's one I agree
okay it was a two-hour speech I guess in
Iowa the other day and he made one or
two small mistake for us
the bigger issue we're running against
Trump I mean people got to keep their
eye on the ball the one thing in these
debates though bill I gotta tell you you
know I hate the back-and-forth the
negativity we need some joyful warriors
out there but we got to start talking
about issues that the public cares about
lower prescription drug costs I haven't
heard k12 I have an infrastructure I
haven't heard cybersecurity I haven't
heard workforce training people at home
want us to try about the issue so right
yeah so
you know we haven't seen much of Obama
which i think is good wear because you
know that's our big secret weapon I
think at the end of the race people
don't really pay attention until after
Halloween of next year yeah so yeah okay
and the US role Michelle in there till
maybe more maybe more so the other big
weapon we used to have is your boy Bill
Clinton yeah but he can't do it now
because we forgave him for 20 years and
then I never saw this we unforgettable I
was like you're forgiven oh no we forgot
we hate you again what he's looking
pretty smart now on the assault weapon
ban he did in 1990 right exactly yeah
so and now it's coming back it's back in
vogue I mean you looked at mass
shootings when that passed in 1994 and
then Bush let it expire mass shootings
went back up again you know there were
some good things I mean it's gun control
it is out of control
so how were the Clintons doing with them
are they doing okay yeah sure I mean
they both have had spectacular lives I
mean he was a great president left with
the highest approve to approve rate of
any two-term press you know neither one
of them ever did this show well that was
a mistake
exactly
[Applause]
you